hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
uh back again with a product review
this is actually an appetizer for uh a
more general topic around
ac mains and and noise and distortion
which uh with any luck i'll record after
this one so after you watch this
uh you may want to tune to that uh uh
video and article
but here i've got a product uh the
audioquest
in the hair grow 1200 it's a
audio sorry it's an ac mains conditioner
or filter
and a surge protector these things come
with a number of different names
um it's a pretty large box i've got it
packed unfortunately so i can't show it
to you but
it's wide i mean it's wider than most uh
than mini stereo equipment
and quite heavy which is nice because
when you plug things into it
hopefully it won't move in my case we're
still sliding around but
maybe if you have it on a wooden table
it wouldn't do that
the owner that sent it to me also sent
two of these uh
beefy power cords uh from them uh
i think the model number yeah nrg nrg-z3
the company recommends these cables so
it was nice to have these cables and and
remove an excuse for uh the results not
being representative
uh there was a long cable two meter one
i think and a one meter one
uh and if you add up all these things
you
get about fourteen hundred dollars uh in
you know about fifteen hundred dollars
in cost
for this setup um
what i do which is kind of unusual but
it makes a lot of sense
is that before i actually power anything
uh through these boxes
i analyze them as if they're black box
after all ac goes into them an ac comes
out
and without looking at the circuits we
can actually characterize what it's
doing
specifically we can characterize what
filtering is doing which is their claim
to fame they all say they reduce
noise and distortion so i hooked it up
to my audio analyzer
and using probes i'm testing what
happens when i feed the uh
just the signal from my audio precision
analyzer into this ac outlet and then
measuring what comes out it's lower than
mains voltage but this device doesn't
care what the voltage is
as far as filtering is concerned and
the blue line is the response of audio
precision by itself just measuring
itself as you can see it's flat line to
well past 100 kilohertz
and then when i hook up the niagara 1200
with the either it's low current outlets
it has these outlets over here they're
lower current and it's got a couple of
high current ones
both low current and high current ones
produce this graph that you see in red
it's actually green and red and so what
this says
is that there's no filtering at all till
you
get past 100 hertz 200 even when you get
to one kilohertz only half a db of
reduction
uh if you pick 3 db as sort of the you
know
so engineering standard of where the
filtering starts
is about five kilohertz so below five
kilohertz the filtering is not that
substantial
and above that filtering increases the
company claims that it has constant
filtering across all frequencies
and i can see that that is approaching
an asymptote where it's flattening out
i don't understand why they think that's
a good idea if a little bit of filtering
is good a lot of filtering is better
so why would you want to filter less the
designer claims that
this is an audible thing that you don't
want to sort of filter some of the
spectrum and not
others but these are all well above
hearing range so
it's not in the hearing range that that
would make sense but outside of hearing
range
seems to me you want to filter a lot
more than five decibels which is all
we're seeing in here
you want to filter 20 30 40 db uh
what have you but any rate um we have
existence proof
that we can fully quantify what this
device is doing as far as filtering
so the notion that we can't measure
these things is completely false uh
it's trivial to measure it and you can
see that we are seeing the measurement
and it is doing something so it's not
just like a power cord or something you
get that
you measure this and it shows no
difference this device is indeed
filtering uh the uh whatever is above
uh five kilohertz or so a few kilohertz
it filters below that has negligible
filtering
uh as a trivial matter our mains
frequency is 50 60 hertz you don't want
to filter any of that because that's
where the juice is coming from
that is the mains feed that comes into
your home so
you don't want to filter that but an
ideal filter would filter
everything about 50 or 60 hertz and
leave nothing there so basically
a brick wall over here and go all the
way out here and even below 50 60 hertz
would
you know output nothing such a filter is
extremely expensive and difficult to
build
um because you're talking very high
voltages and
very steep uh frequency response and
so that's why as a practical matter you
get filters that
mostly are filtering inaudible things
anyway um we don't listen to ac mains
i don't know anybody who takes the ac
cable and sticks to their ear and says
wow that sounds good this doesn't sound
good
so we care about what comes out of our
audio devices
uh manufacturers of course wants us to
want us to focus on you know noise
filtering and everything making you
think that this filtering
one to one applies to your output well
the reality is not that but we don't
want to assume that we want to measure
it so i took my topping a 90
headphone amplifier and preamplifier
it's on my desk i didn't pick it for any
specific reason other than it is state
of the art it is the highest resolution
lowest
noise and distortion device there is
that i've measured in this class
and when we measure it you can see why
the distortion here is minus 140
decibels
uh best case threshold of hearing
relative to 120 db playback
is about -115 so we're way below that
we're 20 30 db below
our threshold of hearing uh with respect
to hearing these harmonic
distortions and so
this device with a generic power cord it
needs no help
uh it's properly designed the engineers
know that
ac mains is never clean and you better
clean that up make it into dc and use
that
but maybe you know better can be had so
i went ahead
and the two tests one is that i continue
to use a generic ac cable that i have a
no name random one but i hooked it up to
niagara 1200
and just to see the benefit of the box
itself
and it shows no benefit the cyanide was
120 db before
and it's 120 db now so this distortion
was minus 140 before it's minus 40 now
everything looks the same i mean these
numbers even down to
like you know four or five decimal
places are are
absolutely not changed so keep in mind
that we're not just looking at a few
numbers in here we have a full spectrum
over here of noise and everything we
actually see a little bit of a 60 hertz
hum in here
which didn't go away it didn't get
changed there's another one over here
it's a harmonic of it
120 hertz that didn't go away so another
thing
changed with this level of precision
error instrumentation down to minus 160
db
we're seeing absolutely nothing there's
no variation
but maybe there's some magic to their
power chords hook up the power chords
by now hopefully you can guess what the
story is like
in that it made no difference whatsoever
with their power chords either
so the performance of this device was
superb before and it's superb now
and this box by the way costs i think
five or six hundred dollars so it's
cheaper than
getting this uh 1400 uh
you know a box of filter ac
uh where you could put your money
towards a box like this that doesn't
need to filter ac
but uh you know you might say well
you know is the device doing anything uh
doing any cleanups
so i did another test and this is a
tricky test please don't go try to
replicate this yourself unless you're an
electrical engineer and you understand
what you're doing
in that i took the ac mains that you
know goes into this and comes out
and using a special differential probe
um
that divides the voltage by a factor of
100
and then fed that to my audio precision
the reason you want to do that is that
the
ac mains 120 volts are a mess the peaks
are 160 170 volts
and it would blow up the audio analyzer
so that's why i'm saying do not go try
this at home and hook it up to some
sound guard or some other
instrument without understanding what
you're doing even if you have a scope
and everything
this is a very dangerous test so please
don't attempt to do it
uh this probe i'm using is differential
and
the nice thing about differential probe
is it doesn't pick up
noise from around the you know extra
noise that's not there so from lights
and other things so it's a very clean
feed to the differential inputs of the
audio precision
so if i just hook that up to my ac mains
that
i power everything with my computer my
other precision analyzer the devices i'm
testing
this is what what it looks like um here
you see what we call the time domain
this is the sine wave
you can see actually the corners are
kind of distorted i'll show you in a
second uh
actually i don't know if i have a clean
one in this one i'll show you in the
next video but the video is
the uh waveform is actually a little bit
deformed it looks like a sideway but
these
peaks are not very clean and the reason
it's not very clean is that if we look
at the spectrum of this if we
apply a fourier transform to it we see
that our mains
uh is at 60 hertz we're i'm in us so we
have 60 hertz uh
ac mains and an ideal power source would
just have that and nothing else
of course not an ideal power source the
power line going through
miles and miles of wiring and does
whatever it wants to do so it comes to
us distorted
and the distortion is fairly horrendous
you can see i've got harmonic distortion
in here and some noises over here that
are modulating
so not a pretty picture um today audio
analyzer though this looks like
audio equipment really this could be an
amplifier measuring with a 60 hertz uh
tone feeding to it so we can do our
normal uh computations on it like th t
plus noise which is what's the harmonic
energy plus the noise energy summed
together
and it's almost two percent one point
nine percent we can convert it even to
synapse like i do with my amplifier and
dac measurements and the cyanide is only
34 db
uh up here you saw the sign out of my
topping was 120
so clearly ac power is not very clean
compared to a
state-of-the-art audio equipment but
there it is
um so then i did the same test this time
i i'm probing what comes out of the
um audioquest niagara 1200 with all
these power cords and everything in here
and the low current outlets which i
assume does more filtering
and guess what happened to the harmonic
distortion and noise
nothing you know they're basically one
point eight nine percent of
the focus 1.9 the waveform is still not
very clean
and all the harmonic distortion
everything is there
why is this the case well i already
showed you why that is the case remember
i said these things
filter mostly high frequencies and they
leave this part of the spectrum between
60 hertz and one or two kilos alone
basically
but you know bad luck that we have where
they have
is that what is all of our noise and
distortion
is all between 60 hertz and one
kilohertz that's where the tallest
and most polluting spikes are
you can try to filter the stuff way down
here uh
20 30 40 50 kills and higher but that's
not going to reduce the total picture
it's like uh you know i don't know if
you
drop a salt water you you put in a pool
is not going to make it salty
so you know if you want to filter ac
mains you need to filter
all of these uh you know objectionable
spikes in here
and this box simply can't do it and none
of them can
as i said that's the size of the machine
expense of
something that can filter down to 50 60
hertz is just horrendous
you're just not gonna get that and
there's really no reason to have it as
i've shown you that
you know that our equipment knows how to
handle this
people always come back and say but but
what did it sound like did you listen to
it
it's a silly question it's like uh
you know a measurement show it makes no
difference whatsoever but
you know i listen because people sort of
comply if i don't so
as it happens this time i started
listening with
with the niagara 1200 and all these
power chords
powering my uh topping a 90
as a starting baseline and then i
switched to the generic cheap
you know two dollar ac code and as soon
as i switched cables to the generic one
the generic one sounded better
if you want to ask is that where does
that get what made the generic cables
out better
it really wasn't any better but the way
your brain works is that you know
when you're first listening to something
as your baseline you're like yeah yeah
i know i know what that sounds like then
you plug in the second one and you start
focusing on paying attention
and also you hear more detail and sounds
higher fidelity
and uh despite all the knowledge i had
by the way i thought this thing worked
out just on all the measurements
the brain still plays that trick on you
you know i heard that is the generic
cable sounded better
what's even more impressive is that when
i hooked it back up to niagara and going
back to that it didn't sound as good
so uh just know that there's these
these perceptions you know that your bra
your brain's perception is just subject
to so much error on this thing that even
the knowledge of that
you shouldn't hear a difference wasn't
enough for me to not hear it
so i'm trying being transparent and
telling you this uh
know that this is why i say subjective
assessments and a lot of reviews for
audio or just total bogus
please don't don't you know pay
attention to them they're good for
entertainment but not much else
so what do we conclude first
you know beyond the device we first
conclude that the people
do audio reviews uh just
spitting out imagination i i don't know
where you know
they don't know the first things about
you know proper evaluation of something
that is
supposed to make a small difference in
that you want to do that test in blind
in a controlled environment
don't just plug it in and let your brain
just be happy that you added this box
that you filtered things therefore the
filtering must have reduced noise floor
therefore the dynamic range improved
veil has been removed base is tight
all these things that you read they make
no sense so
we have john darker over here said he
can't think of any upgrade to his audio
system
that's a better value than than this
1200
that is 1400 dollar gadget
the fact that it makes no difference
whatsoever
clearly it's not the best value is the
worst value spent 1400
some that make no uh difference uh
herba wright character from uh i think
that's how he pronounced his last name
from stereo file um it's the single most
high value component i've ever
auditioned uh for stereo file
well shoot i think you need to go get a
better you know day job or night job
whichever one it is
because this device does not do anything
if they think it does all you got to do
is
turn your back to it have somebody
switch it 10 times in a row
either switch or not switch to another
ac
source and write down a quick log and
show that to us you know
these guys know how to use a video
camera john does a whole bunch of video
youtube videos just
turn your back and you know show us a
video how you can tell 10 out of 10
times
what a dramatic difference it makes
until you do that
you know yes i heard the difference too
although wasn't in favor of this box
um so that's the lesson number one
please don't listen to read and
you know pay attention what what the
subjective reviewers say they're good
people
friendly people great in front of camera
some of them like johnny's
but really they're they don't understand
how you test audio equipment and
uh to just mislead with these statements
um
the other thing you don't want to listen
to is the designer uh they've got this
video on their home page for this device
and uh when you watch him
he you know there's a lot of generic
comments he makes you know that
you know the electricity is old 100 year
old technology as if that's got anything
to do with anything
uh and that all these sources of noise
and rf are terrible
and it's like no they're not terrible
because we don't hear
them everything's the high frequency
that we don't hear we're blessed with
the ears that don't go up to
one megas let alone two three four
giggers where wi-fi and things like that
are
and uh so you filtering those things
does it's no good and by the way if
you're filtering it show us the
measurements
there are no specs there's no
measurements and nothing for this device
i've shown you how simple it is to make
a measurement of
his filtering capabilities show that but
he makes a remarkable statement about
audio that
he says some to the fact of uh the ac
mains can distort or mask
up to one third of your low-level
content
really uh that's a remarkable statement
to make considering that it makes
absolutely no difference electrically in
audio band
and there he's got that thing called the
white paper some obscure
tests that they've thrown together which
it just strains imagination
on this thing note that there are
benefits to these devices potentially
this is also a surge protection device
and
if by all chance you are hearing audible
noise and ticks and pops
maybe this device helps you maybe makes
it worse you don't know but
i'm not evaluating these things as a as
an ac
electrical device if you have bad wiring
in your house and you hook one of these
things up maybe it makes it better maybe
at home
and then you you know added this got
better i don't know
but if you don't have an article problem
you listen to your stereo and it's quiet
and it's playing
and don't go adding this box to it you
don't have a problem
the if you have a problem you'll know it
because it'll make noises
uh one thing about psychoacoustics is
that
our hearing sensitivity is very very
poor in low frequencies
we don't really get sensitive to about
two to three kilohertz
and so a lot of devices could actually
output junk like this
and you don't hear it indeed just about
every amplifier i test there's a lot of
power supply noise
and you don't hear them in low
frequencies you may hear the hiss and
everything at higher frequencies but you
don't hear them at
low frequencies so that's another strike
against them
but uh it's a shame that uh you know
they put out a video with this extremely
misleading comment
uh all they got to do show us a you know
blind test
and uh you know if the difference if one
third of the
music has been taken out you should be
able to tell
it's remarkable that those of us don't
have this device must be missing one
third of our music
i mean can we really believe that one
third of our low level
detail of our music is thrown out
anybody who doesn't have a box like this
and we don't know it
anyway we could raise our blood pressure
on this kind of thing
um as a whole i'm fine with you buying
this box
it seems to be well built a substantial
piece of equipment it's got
non-sacrificial surge protection
uh i've looked at the wiring inside a
little bit unhappy about the way he's
they've wired this stuff up to make it
look pretty as opposed to
a little bit more functional but but
otherwise i
you know i don't have anything bad to
say as a surge protector there are much
cheaper devices you can get
than this but if you want to look at
this thing uh
go ahead and spend a thousand dollars
the power cords i don't recommend
my gosh these things look like they're
going to rip out those ac
sockets out of your devices the dangle
i'm not sure they even make a good
connection because they
torqued your device so much that
i think it's just uh you know unhealthy
for your device let alone your
pocketbook
but there's still work there i see
course they pass ac
so uh you know as a straight device it's
fine
just forget about the audio uh claims
that these companies make
as i mentioned there's another video
coming up after this uh
it's about the whole general area of
noise and distortion on ac
and some cool experiments that take this
kind of review to the next level so see
you in that video
thanks for watching bye